dude holding a wheel that's how you play
man
cool oh yeah there is a man holding a
wheel oh this is about the rake
oh oh it did look very rake-like in the
trailer
oh
horrible no that's cool
no i hate that i hate that
yeah but you hate it because you love it
though no i i actually just
only hate that ah do you want to do
creature on ai first
or one of us yeah ai let's do ai
we need to set our our microphone for
this i am testing
testing me
it works okay my mic is all set up and
good to go i think oh i just realized
they misspelled microphone
and they did microphone microphone
stupid developer stupid hello
testing hello is your output device i
had to change my output device i think i
got it working
okay cool
[Laughter]
are you guys in the lobby penis
enlargement pills or big titties
i'm inviting you to my one
can we all be my character
why not yeah this is the character that
was holding the wheel yeah this has got
to be the best character in the game
really williams real noisy still really
i'm
willy wheely wade what are you wheels
mcfeels
hey there hey bob i'm i'm willy wheely
that's wheely williams william
oh no
are you on wi-fi or something yeah
stinky whiffy if you want to play like
another stuff
that's defective willy
yeah we're good i don't know if i like
that
all right you have no bear ready up here
you're good go
off i'm ready i thought it was just
cause he disconnected
what happened my wi-fi is garbage oh no
no it'll be fine you're good you're good
you're good
it's only periodically oh oh
hello oh jesus oh lens
do you see fear of death and repair man
on your screen i have actually seen
scarecrow
walking yeah i had different things i
didn't remember him because
oh god it's terrible who is that willy
wheely
this is wheelie william jesus christ how
are you doing
oh wow nice face you guys hear something
terrible
oh my god
william um
is he dead
my god jesus christ
guys
guys okay
i'm alone
[Music]
no no my god oh my god
are you dead uh yeah hey how are you
doing are you near me or
i don't think it works like that when
you're dead okay yeah near the rank
yeah uh that was terrifying i i was
somebody else is dead yeah i oh
that that might have been the scariest
thing that's ever happened to me i just
got sick
i lost my mind yeah um
so ai uh rake is very scary i think just
cause we were all talking and being loud
is the main issue
oh yeah i think it might be a little
broken hey how you doing
oh is everyone dead
no he's dead now
[Laughter]
it's a nice body i'm munching on okay
wow
yeah hey guys hey man wow
yeah uh rematch i guess
let's not yell we have to shine our
light at it
oh surely yep also you could press b for
a flashbang it didn't work
it worked for me i only get one
flashbang i'm really glad that uh that
happened like that
i opened a drawer and got jump scared
and then i turned around and there's the
rig
yeah that was pretty cool that's pretty
cool yeah i think uh
just like talking was a bit of a problem
let's not do that again
i don't like how in your my ear you were
so we need a key battery three wheels
and fuel
there's a bar on the right side of our
little task bar that shows how much
noise we make
oh smart okay
just knock you guys [ __ ] walking like
that
there's the three willy wheelies
if i like yell does that raise the
volume try it when mark
loud it went up hey i'm staying away
from him i'm
gonna go over this way yeah [ __ ] at
least compare so we can help
you there's some science here camp barn
number one number two number three hi
i'm going to camp yeah just just come
with me
oh no girls they're dead they're dead
they're dead we're so
alive i can hear you we're alive but
they're dead
don't listen to our private conversation
yeah yeah it's pretty fair
i don't know if the game picks up our
voices like that i think it does but you
were laughing it went up pretty hard
are you alive
yes
stop laughing go away from me
get away
if you did you guys both survive
just step shut shut up stop talking to
me
i got a wheel oh my god
shut up it's fine he's not over here
oh my [ __ ] god don't you all of you
giggling goobers just shut up and go
away this is my house
i actually don't think talking makes a
difference my bar doesn't go up when i
talk
i like that we have lights on our heads
like absolute dweeb machines
yeah you look like you're about to call
the rake's manager i look like i'm
patrolling my neighborhood at night
trying to tell faith
that's exactly it you're telling kids to
stop loitering
mark where the [ __ ] did you go there i'm
trying to sneak away
these fools think that talking doesn't
do it i guarantee it does
there's an extra two
shut batteries so many batteries
[Music]
[Laughter]
hello hey you're the one who found the
lid where's the car sacrificed yourself
for waiting
completely on the other side we have
everything
because it whispering does cause no it
causes noise sweeping
go to the car it causes noise no it
doesn't
yes it does camp left oh my gosh
right oh i see it i see it it's right in
front of me
we want to go away from there there's
camo in the barn that's fine camo in the
barn what does that even mean so loud
it's too loud it's too loud it's too
easy to wear
okay well i i'm fine if you got it just
[ __ ] don't scream around
me i'm fine what mark's saying don't
scream
what does that mean it braces the phone
rough you have noise yeah mark i see
wait just let him know that
jack that guy always saw in the distance
was not stop following me no
did you leave me the car what the [ __ ]
did you see the guy
standing on the boxes i thought that was
one of you
no oh yeah the scarecrow wade no i
thought that was one of you
it was not ah well that's a problem mark
is this quiet enough for you
no hello hello honestly that didn't
raise my bar at all
it raises your yeah me talking doesn't
raise my bar even though it does
you see it's very quiet now
it raises it but not that much
guys please stop talking if i throw a
rock in your direction
yeah wait let me get away i am begging
you guys
that wasn't me
oh you guys aren't yelling now are you
mark shut up do we have all the supplies
someone said we had all yes we do
we just need to find the car that's it
what do you mean find the car the car is
where we started
yeah we don't know where that is follow
me i just came from the car
okay bring us to the car genius i didn't
say anything about my intelligence but
i'm saying about the lack of yours
okay bring us to the car i'm an idiot
that doesn't have the same ring to it
does it well you know what just follow
me following the sound of your voice
or am i do i get to see you or
okay i see that we're going to create an
elaborate signal of flashlight flashes
he's behind me oh my god shut up oh my
god i'll kill you
i'm not that loud i will kill you
can someone tell me where the [ __ ]
carry i just keep going this way
we're going to it follow our voices
who the [ __ ] is that
do you want to tell me who the [ __ ] that
is it's a scarecrow
they're decoys oh okay oh scarecrow
they're decoys
it's a decoy okay wade's coming up
behind us okay i think it's due right
there's a wheel on the ground do we need
another wheel no we do not we just need
to get to the car
okay i think we have all the stuff that
we need okay
i think it's over this way just need to
get to the car oh my god
go to the car at the right it's over on
the right
oh that's [ __ ] bad wait sorry
i think i'm going the wrong way
i'm not going to rise to that you know
like uh
you can't be as funny as i can here
i don't know where i am i don't know
where i keep going in a circle
hello
i don't know how i got this lost i
wasn't that far from the car
when i started i found the car oh my god
where are you hello
[Music]
well i'm dead
well i'm dead and they don't care none
of them ever cared about me anyway
they all just wanted to leave me behind
so i could die
a painful death i don't even know if
they can see me but i'm gonna ride on
the hood of this and i'm gonna take it
to victory
no i can't even ride it wow
you all left me behind you
left me behind what the hell happened
she
inquired her what do you mean i was like
i was talking to you guys
and then you were all gone like i think
we all know who died and who's good at
but
i never said i was good at this game i
was just trying to survive
what else just get kicked out of the
room yeah it keeps me all the way back
to the main menu because you didn't
because you didn't hit rematch yes
stupid batted game person left me behind
i swear you guys were right behind me
and then suddenly i didn't hear you guys
anymore i was like are they messing with
me and then i couldn't see you at all
and then i was in
the complete opposite end of the map
that i thought i was and it was horrible
what if one of us is a monster this time
uh we have to remove the lobby
yeah i mean just i want to see what well
one of you guys can play but i just i'm
curious of what it's like
i'll be a mon okay do it bro do it bro
oh dude it's a cool game it's kind of
like dead by daylight
yeah i kind of like it give the [ __ ]
[ __ ] out of me you know what this game
needs
what's that proximity voice chat here we
go
let's go i'm ready i wonder if i can
hear you
all right so what did we learn last time
to be nice and quiet
what all right let's see what the cars
got i got tow
walking key battery three wheels one
fuel
seems to be the same thing across the
board we keep track of where it is this
time
yeah by the big rock looks like it's the
same is that a scarecrow again
are there just random scarecrows around
there i wonder if they're useful because
you can pick them up what if we just
carry them
just have someone walking next to you
i've got i don't like the scarecrow icon
in my inventory that's not fun
did you throw a rock back half the time
before what the hell
what yeah
[Laughter]
oh man it's weird how the monster talks
to us
can you guys hear me sure can ah that is
weird
wait i couldn't hear him i could hear
him he's cause he's near me
oh you're dead that's why i'm not dead
oh i hear you
you didn't kill me little [ __ ] baby
like you couldn't kill
a rat which you are
howdy boy
you hiding no
well that's a problem you're blind and
you can't you can't see
there we go no [ __ ]
oh i see what you're doing
all right
are they yet where they at where they at
where are they at
you could go for someone else besides me
you and gracious prick
that is [ __ ] loud oh whoops
oh can you can i can you hear me hello
somebody's over this monster hello
hello
i don't think you can hear me hey um hi
hey come on now that's just rude i was
gonna make a deal
like what i don't know what do you want
i want you dead
what else do you want you did that's all
i want
well that seems incredibly challenging
that's really [ __ ] loud holy [ __ ]
what what the hell are we supposed to do
about that once i don't have a flashbang
what am i supposed to do
yeah i don't know man i i don't know how
he sees so i don't know what
what he's dealing with that's true i
feel like
i thought i had got far enough away that
maybe he'd struggle to find the trail
he did not yeah if if he can just see
normally i i don't know what the
flashlights do
i'm not 100 sure wait wait till i get
there i want to see what happens
uh he can't he can't hear us we just
have rat talk
yeah for some reason oh well here's wade
oh [ __ ] i want to see uh
i think i hear jack oh
that was he hid apparently you can hide
that seems really hard it's just
weird that the the monster's voice isn't
distorted in any way
i know i can't find them what the hell
where's where is them
all right then hey
i died so so what is it that you see
it's really dark and you see everything
kind of in red
okay so one thing you see on your radar
you see like little exclamation points
pop up constantly and you just follow
those
oh those must be like noise i'm guessing
and honestly it kind of feels broken to
play as the
monster well i think it's just like we
gotta be actually quiet
and stealthy
[Music]